I've got a touching moment that was  caught on video in Minnesota when a  colorblind students saw color for the  first time  take a look they're all yours that  seventh grader Jonathan Jones his  principal who's also colorblind let him  borrow his special glasses this video  was posted on social media look he's in  tears it was posted on social media last  week by the boy's brother the family  started a GoFundMe page to buy Jones his  own glasses which cost about three  hundred and fifty dollars they had more  than 25 thousand dollars donated  yep because multiple people donated  colorblind glasses to the - Jones the  family is pledging to use the donations  to buy those special glasses for others  who can't afford them you know yeah I  mean I'm partially colorblind and my  kids are always telling me you should  get those glasses dad  I mean $50,000 is a lot for glasses $350  Oh $350 oh very good very good all right